time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week heart
disease is the nation's number one
killer and a new study says many who
appear to be living healthy lives could
still be at risk the study appears this
week in the Journal of the American
College of Cardiology it included nearly
1,800 participants without traditional
cardiovascular risk factors that means
among other things they were non-smokers
with normal blood pressure the study
sought to identify predictors of a
sometimes hidden risk factor plaque
buildup in arteries here to discuss the
findings is CBS News medical contributor
dr. Tara Narula doc great to see you
morning Alex so what are predictors of
plaque you know so one of the Holy
Grails in cardiology is trying to
predict who's gonna have a heart attack
and stroke before it happens because it
the problem with cardiovascular disease
is that it can be silent until you have
an event so what do we use we use
traditional risk factors like you have
high blood pressure do you smoke but
what this is telling us is that that may
not be good enough because in fact 50
percent of those who had normal
traditional risk factors had plaque in
their arteries and not at age 70 or 80
these were 40 to 50 year olds one-third
of those who had optimal risk factors
had plaque in their arteries Wow so what
seemed to matter in this study was being
a male age and LDL so this is kind of
the big finding of this study is that
LDL or bad cholesterol may hold the key
to why young people who seem otherwise
healthy may be having heart attacks all
right so as the study focuses on our
artery health what what should we take
away from it in terms of preventing this
so again it comes back to what can we
really control partially and that is
cholesterol and so LDL there's been a
lot of controversy well does cholesterol
really matter well it does we have a lot
of research and here's another study
telling us that not only does it matter
but it matters to pay attention early so
everyone should start getting screened
they should know their numbers as early
as age 20 and what the other interesting
thing about this study was that even LDL
numbers that were considered normal
meaning like around 150 to 160 about 60%
of those people had plaque in their
arteries so really it seems that once
you go above an LDL of 50 or 60 which is
pretty low you start to develop plaque
so
pay attention to diet exercise weight
loss that matters all right next up
still on the topic of heart health but
this time affecting newborn babies some
states have implemented mandatory
screening among all infants for what's
known as critical congenital heart
disease
a recent observational study published
in the Journal of the American Medical
Association looked at the impact of
these screening policies researchers
examined data from 2007 to 2013 looking
at infant death rates they found that
nearly 3,000 infant deaths resulted from
critical congenital heart disease the
study assessed whether States
implementing mandatory screening
guidelines saw declines in death rates
okay that's the deep tease did they see
it decline with these screenings they
did and Alex you just had a baby I mean
you know one of the first things you
wave from the delivery room the cry to
know the baby's okay then before you get
discharged did they pass their screening
tests yeah and the screening tests for
critical congenital heart disease really
became recommended not that long ago in
2011 and so when they looked at eight
states that kind of changed their
recommendations in this time period they
found a 33 percent decrease in infant
deaths from critical congenital heart
disease and a 21 percent decrease in
infant deaths from others causes
unspecified cardiac causes we know that
7,200 babies a year are born with
critical congenital heart disease and
you need to pick it up early because
even though they may look healthy in the
hospital when they go home those first
couple days and weeks they could be at
risk for cardiac collapse for dying but
picking it up early means they can get
really diagnosed they can get treated
with either surgery or the procedures
that they need while it's a game change
and it's a simple test it's called the
pulse oximetry test all it's doing is
measuring the pulse and the oxygen level
in the blood of the baby all right dr.
Tara Narula thanks so much for being
here this morning